The movie prefecture is dangerous, it's
dangerous.  They're talking about rubber to raise funds for robot development.They're the
ones who could make an anime
where robots lose to the living.Giant robots are spooky, so it's amazing here.Look, the
video rights are under control.  It's a scenario
It's always something like this We have to think about it once again
Eizo Kengo From time to time Letter 1 soon after the 4th
We have to be ranked ninth in the video prefecture before we get to write a bizarre robot
. Ah, it seems we are not trusted by our clients
.
I will continue to make effective use of this excellent document.
Mr. Kanamori is good at talking to people. This is not a conversation.